confiné rose est effectivement va
vouloir gagner faut pas lâcher comme
dire notamment les supporters qui
commente avec nous la course et voilà on
veut rien on va x est pas figé en aura
on aura un peu je pense l'arrivée de
l'an dernier parce que félix aussi ellis
perrine je voulais faire champions il a
une petite revanche à prendre l'an
dernier puis c'est elle qui a fait avoir
dans un tout petit temps sur la ligne
d'arrivée
on va contourner la mort de jacqueline
on va rentrer et on va passer on va
arriver à laon chaudière donc là on est
sous la cote on n'a pas beaucoup de vent
c'est vraiment la main légère et ses
quatre sont dans un mouchoir de poche au
foyer valais on est on à en apprécier
toutes les viols à monza mise à
l'enchère voilà la cause par cofely gens
loin de là loin de là loin de là ophélie
s'il est des copains se bat devant bras
ce qui peut prendre la tête il reste à
terre la voile laval et au milieu si
vous de la voile son plein vent arrière
donc à n'importe quel moment ils peuvent
faire passer la voile en panne et mais
pour le moment c'est wire le sont toutes
les trois tribord amure bord à bord on à
l'agglo dit on a des bassines et on voit
comment on va alors je peux vous dire
quelque chose si c'est théoriquement
c'est la voie la plus importante
pourquoi c'est l'om qui est au vent eh
ben elle devrait être un petit peu
avantagé mais il faut qu'elle joue bien
aucun jeu bien faut qu'elle en panne un
petit peu tout voyez là on est tous le
monde et tribord amure
on essaie de passer félix ne va pas trop
se coller à rose elle il laisse penser
que les deux devant pourquoi il ya de la
tension à bord vraiment beaucoup et
l'attention parce qu'elle voyait la
voile est passé de l'autre côté o'grady
la voile de rosette qui est passé aux
états aux est à changer la voix les
babors la voile passer dépasse ou jeu
tout le temps toute entière se cherche
on la laisse battre et on laisse passer
la phoenix est organisé depuis il a
gardé sa voile paris non mais c'est neuf
ans qui fête le vin étonnant voyage à 10
mètres de long 20 mètres à deux
longueurs de york en avant différents
nous venger la fois du fn ne bouge pas
autant que celle de celle de zapper ici
est celle de brasse tout à fait je vous
dis hélas la voile et rationalisant tous
les sens sur oise et orale bon mais ce
sera tout voilà notre fameux jacques et
nous on est là soit ya beaucoup de vent
sur la bonne voie et dans les deux cas
on est beaucoup l'attention envoyer un
petit vent devant donc la vallée bordée
à voile et bordé la voix lui a fait
légèrement gourde et vous sortir de ce
trou comme un homme et sur le bateau la
même ligne j'envoie album voit le bord
des voies le border ya pas de sens c'est
le règne à petite vitesse
elles sont dues à la pluie et au vent la
voile rouge et blanche brasserie
lorraine mais pour le moment elle
prendre l'avant et comme elle aime voile
un peu plus important dès que le vent
est très faible
elle a pris la main et celle qui sortira
de celle qui va gagner l'étape
c'est déjà celle qui va essayer
d'arriver de parts après ça en allant
choisir
il ya un deuxième différence de ces
personnes deuxième rappel à l'ordre et
plus on va essayer d'aller à la bouille
fait à manger aux mails aide à passer du
combat du combat du de faveur il ya du
combat sait mettre l'ambiance est là
derrière le mettre derrière voilà le jeu
monte monte monte monte blessés même
stratégie différente que ça va nager
nouvelle
j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont beaucoup
plus forts à la godille faire un gros
plan peut-être alors je sais pas si on
va réussir
du côté donc des images de jeux manqués
dégâts voire un peu
ouais combat au camp gbagbo dit parce
que là effectivement ça se joue à la
godille on voit que champions ils sont
peut-être sec sur la pagaie mais on
essaiera de vous montrer cette image
tout à leur attention avec une faible
chance voilà attention attention c'est
celui qui va toucher le vent le premier
parce que là le vent vient de tous les
sens donc il faut vraiment savoir
peut-être laissé filer la voix le voir
dans quel sens le vent 20 points de
dents pour pouvoir repartir
je crois que sous cet exercice donc je
reste collé et puis on va voir ce qui se
passe mais pour le moment il peut pas
c'est pas la peine d'abattre quand
tomber sur les autres c'est pas la peine
de monter trou est vrai celle cherche du
vent voilà donc l'année dernière
effectivement on a eu c'est un même
arrivé et ce duel qu'on avait l'année
dernière entre euros cette roche et il a
fait un champion dont à la même chose
s'il a perdu ses recours fait j'espère
qu'ils se rappellent pas trop vous pas
trop simple il faut se rappeler des
choses positives
alors nous allons voir derrière c'est
vrai qu'il ya cette bagarre en tête de
course entre quatre viols ufr chanson
rose et or aux appétits l'appaloosa et
brasserie lorraine et puis derrière donc
la cinquième qui arrive l'appareil c'est
cette aide et mdf qui se trouve dans la
même configuration que les quatre viols
qui précède donc
l'embarcation de mario marc fleury voilà
il faut beau dire allez faut pagayer
faut faire avancer la vacation et il
faut essayer de trouver ce petit vent là
pour essayer justement de se rapprocher
donc de ces quatre yole de tête de
course nathalie guillien valeurs dites
nous tout est à quel niveau nathalie et
je suppose que vous vivez comme nord-est
magnifique spectacle nathalie
bon l épave bruit nathalie elle est
prête elle n'est pas prête
bon on va retrouver leurs portes on va
la retrouver tout à l'heure d'aller
royal avec elle a accepté
natalie rigal oui je voudrais vous
montrer une image parce qu'on est entre
petite anse et les anses d'arlet et il
est très très rare que les bateaux
suiveurs que les plaisanciers soit aussi
près de la côte est aussi près des yoles
donc ils profitent pleinement du
spectacle et des viols qui vont vers
l'arrivée dans une joyeuse pagaille
regardez plutôt ça alors les
commissaires se battent évidemment avec
eux pour les reculs hercules et toutes
ses dents de deux au moins la première
ligne des bateaux suiveurs enfin des
plaisanciers mais c'est compliqué parce
que là vraiment tout le monde a envie
d'en profiter du spectacle
oui parce qu'on arrive aussi dans cette
charmante commune d installer et y ait
ce flou qui a pris anti vont arriver
fake est resté à l'extérieur qui a pris
le vent et faire qui prend la tête de
course un jean ufr qui reprend la tête
de course et faire qu'ils
se positionnant devant rosette/orange
bras ce qui l'aurait de sart énergies
nouvelles et zapetti l'appaloosa mais
quelle cause qu'elles causent footbag à
la belle on a des rebondissements donc
pratiquement donc tout le temps avec
cette zone d'accalmie la au niveau du
monde jacqueline on avait les quatre y
sommes sur la même ligne est plus là
justement les positions sont en train de
changer d'être modifié parce qu'on
approche aussi de l'arrivée et on on
voit que les équipages se sont enduits
faut aller gagner il faut cette victoire
d'étape et la championne qui veut se
faire respecter qui a repris la tête de
course et qui devance donc vous êtes
orange mais qui reste quand même sous la
menace des deux autres viols que
s'embrasser lorraine sahara et les âges
innovait les appétits l'appaloosa will
et wayolle de tête en grosso modo la
même vitesse si vous voulez qu'ils se
refusent pas tarder à laguiole brasserie
lorraine sarr énergies nouvelles restent
toujours au vent de aux plus avancés à
10 ans si le vent forcit un petit peu si
le vent vient devant je vais peut-être
point de ce vent avant rossetto il faut
pas oublier qu'elle est en compétition
avec rosette orange ou la deuxième place
tant pour le moment elle suit elle peut
pas faire autre chose que ça on l'a
laissé l'an chaudière moi je crois que
tous les bateaux qui a light était pas
c'était trop de nombreux qu'on l'aimé
talent chaudière c'est la raison pour
laquelle on lit certains à l'extérieur
mais il faut vraiment non seulement
qu'ils ne gênent pas ces quatre wayolle
qu'ils sont en tête
faut pas qu'il gêne c'est aider m qui
vient derrière et puis le peloton
les 11 autres wayolle qui sont un peu
plus en arrière là voilà on revient la
tête locaux ça va se jouer où ça va se
jouer à pas grand-chose à pas grand
chose
félix mérine un vent différents voyages
indifférent le vent vient de le vent ils
essaient de monter au maximum pour
mettre les adversaires derrière dans son
devant dans son axe de manière à éviter
toute surprise qui est un vent qui
viennent de la terre qui les emmènent
montella on est retombé en on voit au
fond de relents chaudière ou ailleurs
quelques bateaux qui ont été mis là mais
comme ils sont un peu loin
ils ne gênent pas boulot moment là on en
a quand même si c'est assez calme comme
bon c'est pas du tout les styles et les
ce qu'on avait prévu comme avant il ya
un peu moins de vent sur cette pente et
juba en cours et je peux vous dire que
là c'est extrêmement difficile parce
qu'on a on a en outre deux heures de
cause sont on est fatigué c'est tendu on
sait qu'on a fait tout à l'heure où on
est et netease un parent pas grave on
n'a pas fait ce qu'il fallait et on sait
que les quatre équipages des soldats ils
sont extrêmement motivés toi qui peux
gagner cette étape
une des quatre jeunes lecteurs mais
c'est trop facile non c'est pas facile
parce que si on a la configuration on
s'approche de la ligne
ça pose à l'abri numéro 3 le bruit ou
trois points 3 mais nous n'avons pas on
n'a aucune indication du vent qui lie à
la salle yeux que ce soit il peut y
avoir un petit vent qui vient dont va
bénéficier bresse que l'om soit ça peut
continuer côté spurs n'en est plus là ça
peut venir de derrière et puis fr
championnat et éliminé comme l'an
dernier et puis vous êtes souvent
derrière il fit le savoir et il le passe
on dit comme une gouille donc c'est très
ouvert très ouvert un jeu ne botte pas
en touche je vous dis que c'est
difficile vous êtes devant vous vous
devez négocié regarder avec les
consignes à bord la marche de votre
bateau et vous devez vous préoccuper de
ceux qui sont derrière parce qu'on l'a
toujours en tête la victoire d'étape
là on fait on n'est pas question de dire
il va arriver deux minutes avant moi
comme il l'a 12 minutes de calcul ne
calcule pas on va la gagne au jour du
bios et de ses quatre adjoints la gagne
l'ufr chance lors pour garder sa
suprématie brasserie lorraine parce
qu'il sait qu'il a le potentiel d'autant
qu'il a une voix un peu plus grand donc
il sait qu'il est un peu avantagé
vous êtes orange pense qu'il va la
gagner il a quelque chose à vendre à ses
équipiers et puis à ses équipes et à son
corps pas ses supporters à ses
partenaires et puis zapetti la part
losail dans le même cas de figure du 7e
art et pis c'est une gentille et a vendu
avant un autre classement mais bon on
essaie de remonter
remonté avec du gingembre donc on se fie
la chose ou ne faut pas être voilà en
bas on va embarquer certainement un
équipier parce qu'ils voient qu'à des
petites cerises et de vendu ce qu'a
annoncé du frais peut-être le pinceau
parce que s'il y en embarquent de l'oif
au pouvoir en enlever quelqu'un posé la
question il ya qu'est-ce qu'on met un
bon c'est vrai qu'on essaie de mettre le
moins de choses que possible à eux
n'étant pas très lourde
on met le minimum même pas un sou parce
qu'on sauve pesé donc si on a besoin du
soir ne demande la valeur une belle
bagarre entre ces trois jeunes et un
petit peu de vent tu peux devant tous
m'ont abordé les voit donc les lions
sont va partir entre joue pareil
d'ailleurs parce que lauren sahara qui
est censé avoir une voile plus grande
mais le souci vous devez vous habituer
bateau j'ai dit vous allez pouvoir
unique aux notes ni patrons les
plusieurs éléments alors si vous avez la
bonne voix loin devant par contre j'ai
franchement on n'a pas la même valeur
que les autres sont en train de dériver
sourire toute vitesse
ayala bruit il est à la bouée il est à
l'abri il va falloir arriver à la ligue
1 nous sommes à l'abri à l'abri regarder
derrière il ya pas tellement le vent
donc ce qu'il va faire il va monter il
va monter monter à l'est vers la côte et
puis la voix pour contrôler contrôler
les deux autres qui arrivent derrière
comme une bombe comme une bombe comme
une voile alors on va voir ça on va
suivre effectivement donc
donc ça c'est la bourre expériment qui
se reprend de son montéchois total de
121 m on va dire me citer erreur de tout
à l'heure et qui remet les pendules à
l'heure qui va passer donc cette bouée
en première position et après qui va
filer donc vers l'arrivée du côté des
essences dans les ufr champion qui a
voilà quatre projets un petit écart mais
attention là parce que là il ya une
bagarre entre brasser le raid israélien
nouvelle et rosette orange mais
effectivement sauf avarie
j'en parlais tout à l'heure du vent mais
on va voir ensemble on va le fond oui
avant 6 mai brasserie lorraine sarah ça
va se jouer à quelques secondes 24 26
secondes pour brasser lorraine sahara et
rosette orange 24 26 secondes zapetti
l'appaloosa cabine hidayat 40 secondes
et attention tous peaufiner qui
s'activent et rosette orange qui
sacrifie la révélation c'est une ville
il est guéri il a viré pour le
paraissait y voit que félix mérine
continue s'est dit je fais ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure la course
n'est pas terminée
il précède vous avez les yoles dans deux
bords différents félix mérine est en
train d'aller sur un bord tribord amure
mais fait recette mélasse delà de la
ligne d'arrivée félix où il a dû avoir
joué depuis longtemps il va se faire
avoir au vont parler parler de viol qui
sont très souvent ils auraient dû avoir
viré faire comme poser pour l'aca il ya
deux choses il est soit on va la jouer
soit on fait du contrôle s'il fait du
contrôle il a deux volumes de viol qui
sont derrière lui d'ailleurs les
appétits qui est sous le vent ça fait
tilt appel aux arts et puis brasserie
lorraine sahara qui j ai maintenant tout
le monde y compris le yen que
stratégique
on va voir ce que ça va donner par
rapport aux bords il va se retrouver à
voir avec le choix de rosette orange qui
fit remettre aux adhérents du gie pour
revenir
tout ça parce qu'on ne sait pas quel est
le vent mais disons qu'il va faire se
rapproche de la wii alors on va voir ça
y est on est entré dans ce jeu de
stratégie avec shakespeare in qui a viré
rosette qui a décidé de virer maintenant
mais ce que le choix de acco sera payant
on le saura dans quelques instants au
bon dieu que c'est chaud umaga label
tout bonnement entre ufr champions
rosette/orange zapetti l'appaloosa et
brasserie lorraine qui connaît aussi ce
plan d'eau on va voir ça parce qu'on
approche de cette arrivée où
effectivement chacun va chercher le vent
chacun va essayer de tirer un bon chacun
essaie de rentrer directement et à ce
petit jeu là peut-être peut-être que
brasserie lorraine va sortir vainqueur
évocation priorité limo ramin
rosette/orange à la priorité à l'eau
soit pas soit effectif rennais non vous
êtes orange a la priorité
vous êtes aura la priorité s'il a eu le
bras ce qui est passé de avancer parce
qu'elle pouvait passer devant ça a été
très très très juste ça a été très juste
elle est passée devant voilà un bel
exemple de croisement alors voir ce que
l'on va vivre il faut qu'elles virent
maintenant pouvoir tourner vers la ligne
d'arrivée retourner vers une affaire
chamfort value fr champagne est en train
de monter va durer les lecteurs
non il va pas virer parce qu'ils voient
comment ça se passe il contrôle et
contre la cause s'ils voulaient
contrôler la course il a laissé tomber
aux étrangers il va maintenant voyez il
ya une ado n'a pas gardé le vent la
yolette entre lgt savez qu'il ya du vent
il borde ses voiles mais est ce que le
vent important pour lui il va assurer la
couverture il va pas encore viré ça que
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure la course
n'est pas terminée
on l'a fini après la bouillie la mettre
dans les deux écoles constituent
brasserie lorraine sarah énergies
nouvelles et rose et orange sont en
train de repartir sur un bord tribord et
l'extérieur félix mérine vient vers la
côte donc se rapprochent se rapproche de
sa bouille et puis dans le fond vous
avez appétit l'appaloosa qui essaie de
nous faire le coup tout à l'eau et la
boue et jusqu'à au donc ça pétille
essaie de nous faire le coup tout à
l'heure d'aller jusqu'à la côte
peut-être se disant qu'ils ont un petit
ventre qui va venir le tir là s'ils
voulaient soul et royaumes mais félix
mérine avis les maîtres lestoille en
tribord amure félix mérine et au vent
avec un petit peu moins de vent sarah
non il fait il fait pas encore la bouffe
est pas encore là bas il faut qu'ils
aillent vers la terre donc ils sont dans
la bonne direction pour le moment et
puis attendez il suivait ce que je fais
zap et il appelle aux as parce que ça
pétille ça pétille et de l'autre côté au
fond de notre écran vous voyez quand on
voit les bateaux à la boucle à la bouée
à vis des bruits à virer sont de l'autre
côté tout au fond donc on voit
maintenant 20 maintenant on contrôle la
métaphysique ces fonds qu'ils contrôlent
rosette orange peut vivre et il peut
être un petit mot il va falloir virer
parce que là on voit bien en bonne
position bruce keller ali saremi a novel
il a fait un champion pour moi un petit
en place va se jouer entre ces deux nous
appétit ou a vendu saab et isabella ciel
devenant à betty va passer devant au
détour sap et il va passer il assure il
est allé à terre je vous ai dit tu as la
stratégie et c'est de rentrer
directement mais on n'est pas encore en
s'occupant de la bouillante chaque bord
confit d'oie nous approcher de la wii
donc on n'est pas de suite directe il
est allé à tiens il a fait son petit
bonbon rose et orange a compris que ça
ne valait pas le coup donc ils vivent
donc on va voir le croisement maintenant
entre eux c'est du viol constitue l'ufr
changement la voix blanche et brasserie
lorraine sarah énergies nouvelles avec
sap et il a pas l'audace et de viols
sont prioritaires et son stylo un mur je
pense qu'elle va passer derrière la yole
brasserie lorraine est derrière appétit
il va nous rester à savoir le croisement
avec ufr chancelant sauf si fr champions
se décide de virer parce qu'elle est en
position favorable et la ligne est la
ligne la non la ligne est pas encore là
il va passer il va passer sa bêtise à
bettié devant sa bouche est allé devant
elle et devant elle va virer maintenant
ou contrôlées ne sait pas si elle peut
être qu'elle fait là but autrement si
elle ne fait pas la ligne elle va agir
et vous soumettre au vent le félix prix
félix a commis la même erreur que tout à
l'heure il est allé ewell entre
guillemets qu'ils me pardonnent elle est
allée trop loin dans son bord là où la
yole faits sont morts tranquillement
pour aborder
il faut que mme erin firme maintenant
ils vivent qui se met dans son coin
c'est pas grave parce que ce qui va se
passer c'est que rose et orange va
tenter d'aller au fond ou prendre
revenait aussi bora mur et pour prendre
cette 2e place la deuxième de la 2e
place maintenant est en jeu la première
place est quasiment acquise la deuxième
place appétit la panoz abaisser la balle
aux à félix mérine devrait viser pas
pourquoi ils sentent être aller jusqu'au
fond
il devrait durer peut-être qu'ils vous
regardent et qui voit que l'iphone ne
fait pas encore la bouée elle ne fait
pas encore la ligne d'arrivée elle fait
pas encore un diamant mais elle s'en
rapproche
et vous êtes au fond est allé remettre
dans les bateaux il va vous dire qu'ils
étaient dans les bateaux mais est allé
trop loin
il y aura tiré là aucun droit viennent
voilà lier la sueur elle assurait les
devants
raison pour laquelle joue d'habitude
tout à l'heure que la cause de ce que je
lançais de vous et les questions de
stratégie m
à se battre entre elles et royal on a
laissé une fois de plus filer une yole
qui passe au vent et les montres et bien
souvent elle a regardé comment ça se
passait là vu les conditions
atmosphériques petit en levant vienne
terre je vais à terre et je me rapproche
de ma vie même si je ne la fait pas là
ils sont ils sont tous prêts même si la
coupure pub aura fait un petit bond est
un petit bourg breton juste un petit mot
pour couper la ligne d'arrivée qui vont
couper en vainqueur mettra derrière
c'est la deuxième place qui est en jeu
on va reprendre émergents où elles sont
voilà donc ça fait tilt appaloosa qui va
donc s'imposer du côté d installer ça y
est ils ont tiré leur bord est ce que je
gagne un lot à thierry mais attention
parce que c'est pas fini
c'est pas philippe asker et moody's ait
quoi que tu lui mets les cours pas
passer les pour papa si ils vont devoir
virer en corée attention parce qu'aig a
daigné faire cabinet ou là attention
jean toulon savoir qui va arriver
ufr aimable le ferry ben yahia qui
arrivent les bâbord amure il est chaud
il va arriver il va faire les appétits
ufr l'appétit ou fr jean zapetti ufr
cinq ans et c'est une demi longueur sa
bêtise à betty et faire qui va sur la
bouée attention là les appétits de ses
priorités
donc ce n'est garanti l'appétit qui
gagne je pense que c'était chaud je
pense aux appétits
mais bon j'espère que la volonté
réclamations lorsque vous qui va partir
il s'agira boucher félix mérine la vie
ou un peu tabou combo ça ne se fait pas
mais c'est qui qui va porter réclamation
du zapetti s'ils sont mauvais
non ça va les brassages et plaçait alors
on va vérifier ça parce qu'on a
l'impression que brasserie donc prend la
deuxième place 3e on connaît la
troisième parce que ufr était seul à
bord est alors est-ce que effectivement
on a eu la sonnerie indique un passage
mais oui mais ils ont touché la bouée et
on n'avait pas ce qu'ils auraient leur
entrée donc on va demander la pareille à
nathalie williams de se rapprocher tout
à l'heure d'une région comme isler
jugeons pas ces gens parce qu'ils ont
passé parce qu'ils ont tenté de passer
de ne pas prendre le tribord amure ne
pas s'étendre aux appétits et l'amour
alors on va voir si on en a la
confirmation dans un instant parce
qu'effectivement tellement le truc était
chauve on peut ça s'est joué entre
abrite il a pas longtemps et a fait un
champ fleurs et même brasserie lorraine
bull toit pour un p tit deuxième place
alors là encore on verra tout à l'heure
est ce que c'est
les frères champlain est ce que ces
bracelets lors elle sarah et puis le
bord le coup tenté parce que
effectivement c'est un coup de poker cas
et c'est jacques amadou diack au procès
de s'imposer du côté des sens dans
l'herbe et non ça n'a pas payé polonais
du couple c'est fini 4e de l'étape 11
ans dans l'émergence de gates est belle
pagaille qui chante je vous l'avais dit
ça ne se joue pas ça se joue à deux
niveaux au niveau tactique personnel et
puis niveau même trois niveaux au niveau
évaluation du vent de la direction du
vent et puis contre les abs voilà donc
cette étape riche en rebondissements
on a eu plusieurs fois
des changements tête de course on a eu
dans un premier temps brasserie lorraine
ensuite d'eau en plus c'était de me dire
ensuite lui ai fait un chanteur après c
était le tour donc pour rosette/orange
après piscine donc et même appétit après
donc la chance laure a repris la tête
pour ce faire carrément coiffer main
vraiment un sur la ligne d'arrivée
autant aller par un appétit l'appaloosa
avec des jeux de bord petit beaugrand
bord voilà bref mais c'était une arrivée
un extraordinaire belle quand même avoir
une belle régate était magnifique
effectivement les spectateurs ont dû
vibrer les supporteurs francisco comme
les supporteurs marinois et même les
supporteurs robertet ont donc vibrer et
sur cette arrivée du côté des anglais
qui encore une fois nous gratifie d'une
superbe arrivée comme l'année dernière
kelly babou on va la retrouver tout de
suite sur la plage
kelly trois heures du matin
[Musique]
au 26 emblématique du monde mais après
on a réfléchi il se serait plus est
bonne on est sur deux étapes dont celle
d'elie baup a osé donc nous on va
diminuer aussi par rapport au nombre de
couleurs vont à la pêche faty s'est
bâtie comme jadis sont souvent c'est pas
forcément la petite est drôle c'est plus
que tout c'est ça s'est joué à ça près
on appelait il ya un combat qui était
vraiment mais vraiment très très bas oui
mais en fait pour monter on entendait
quand même
et un petit bon endroit donc on n'a pas
ce faire il a joué c'est normal on la
veut toucher la bouée de l'arrivée c'est
bien après ces temps là j'ai failli être
produits soient plus vigilants mais non
c'est pas qui on a vu son horizon
or ce qt ou verse le mois le plus fort
déjà belles choses madonna profiter on a
dit des bons de la bérézina